campbell here on the rich eisen show
after handling the business like that
how are you caleus campbell
i'm doing fantastic how are you doing i
am doing fine uh again i i i'm sure
did they say that to you after you
required that
that derek henry they just told me that
like there's a lot of teams that
you know do uh they play that zone
scheme that i have done well against and
throughout my career
right and so they're looking forward to
me being able to you know help with that
but
you know there was no direct you know
you're here to stop derek here or
anything like that
you know it's just you know my mom said
you know they brought me here to try to
win the super bowl
and we got a lot a lot more work to do
i'm sure no doubt about that
but that said um there
what was the emphasis on derek henry
this past week that you were able to put
into practice
and then actually onto a field and
succeed with
calais what was that about yeah i think
uh
you know for first thing i give a big
shout out to coach wink
you know i mean he put together a great
defensive game plan
and uh we knew what was going to give
him some some fits just because the way
they like to where they like to attack
you know i mean we you know we put uh
people in position to make much adjust
and then uh just uh guys being
relentless and uh and playing good
just tackling well you know you knew i
mean he's a tough task for anybody you
know to tackle so we have to bring the
cavalry
and uh you know you see a lot of times
where one person hits them but then
right you know within another second you
got three more people on top of them
and that was crucial to our success and
um did you sense his frustration
throughout the day well yeah i mean
football's an emotional game
and you know when things don't go the
way you want them to go you know it's
natural to get a little frustrated
and so i mean he loves the game of
football off computer gets him quite a
bit
and i respect the way he plays the game
and uh yeah it's only natural for him to
get a little frustrated not being able
to do what he wants to do but like i
mean i've seen him
you know we bottle him up for four for
three quarters and then you know he just
gets going in the fourth so
you know uh it's a testament to our
defense to just to stand strong
and and uh to keep pressing you know in
the situations where
you know he was he had a couple times we
almost got out of there and we found a
way to get him down
speaking of an emotional game callius
before the game uh on nfl game day
morning i'm sitting there on the set
uh of course it you know irv will
mention that you and he went to the same
school at the u like literally every two
seconds but outside of that
yep exactly outside of all that um we
saw
a shot of the ravens leaving the field
just before
kickoff i guess going back into the
locker room one last time and you seem
to be barking at somebody you seem to be
we
saw that on camera were you i don't know
where you were you were you barking at
somebody on the titans or
trying to rally your teammates what was
that one about calais uh it was
it was i mean it wasn't like it looked
probably worse i seen the video and it
looked worse than what it really was
right but
you know i was definitely talking but it
was more in the sense of like we're here
today
you know we're coming you know with
everything we have you know y'all better
be ready and this will be a battle
you know kind of there's more for my own
teammates just to let them know
like you know bringing the energy you
know starting right away look at them in
their face and let them know
it's going to be a long day for them you
know and that it's just you know it's i
mean
it's playing football you know you know
get the emotions flying early
you know get the juices flying early so
we go out there and i mean we still got
down 10 early
you know so i mean uh but my goal was
forced to start fast
uh but the good thing was nobody
panicked we just kept playing good
football
but yeah my whole goal was just just to
get
get it sparked early get the energy and
the momentum sparked early so it was a
general message for anybody with an
earshot
uh that was not uh it was not directed
at anybody uh
with a t on the side of their house you
know but i was saying it in the sense
for my teammates to hear in the sense of
that we're ready and uh that it's gonna
be a long day for you you know we're
coming with everything we got
and you know pretty much i mean it
wasn't i mean you know i don't
talk a lot of trash you know i'm not
gonna you know talk you know reckless
anybody but i
just wanted the titans to know that we
would come with everything we had and it
was gonna be a long day for him
and especially when i got to the o-line
you know that's what i think the video
kind of shown we're talking to the line
and i've had some good battles against
you know most of those guys over there
you know being in the same division for
a long time so
very familiar with them that's right
competed and had a lot of a lot of
history so i was kind of you know
seeing uh ben jones you know he kind of
started clapping and that and then uh
uh southport you know kind of you know
they responded in a way where i expect
them to because their competitors you
know they're not going to lay down
and that's going to be a competition and
uh you know i think it was it was just a
playoff football right guys we're gonna
leave that playoff football
clay scampel here on the rich eisen show
and then what was with the logo dancing
at the end of the
the end of the game what was going on
with that one
yeah i mean that was kind of far at the
moment you know i um you know it's just
i think uh you know
wanted one to win the game you know want
to win the game but i think there was
definitely some
you know respect factor that uh that
comes in
to play when you uh you know everybody
was talking about how
you know before the game earlier in the
regular season where they kind of stood
at the logo
and uh coach harbaugh didn't like that
very much and you know went up and said
something about it and it became like
kind of a big deal
and just naturally as competitors you
know
that was something that rubbed a lot of
us the wrong way but you know we won't
make a big deal about it because the
reason we want to win the game is to go
to you know have a chance to win a super
bowl
but that's just a little extra
motivation and uh you know i think uh
a lot of the guys take it very
personally and so it was one of those
things where you know when the game was
kind of we thought we got the game in
control
uh you know i think the guys want to
send a message but hey
you know i spurred a moment from from my
voice but you know i was just
happy that we found a way to win the
ball game and uh you know i mean
let them know that uh yeah we didn't
like that too much six-time pro bowler
class campbell here
uh on the rich eisen show so
where did things turn for this team when
when when
when was the when was the moment uh
clearly we all know the covet hell is
the only way to put it that your team
was going through you got
coveted 19. um and then
you know uh the cowboys game gets played
after the steelers game in which uh half
the team wasn't even there
on a on a middle of the of the week
but the game was really close uh where
what's the moment calais where where
things began to change for the better
for your team
you think you know honestly i felt like
um you know
it was a lot of ups and downs and you
know we have moments we played
really good ball and moments where we
just you know we couldn't put it
together
and i i feel like uh you know what we
kind of got to spark because when uh
lamar came back after getting an iv
against the browns
uh to to you know to win that ball game
after being up and kind of going back
and forth in that ball game
uh and he needed a big play and lamar
coming back in and
that kind of was like that was a big
moment for our team now obviously
you know i mean we still got so much
more ball to play and you know
you know we're not satisfied with
winning one game in the playoffs you
know i mean
you know we got a big challenge this
week and it's going to be a very tough
matchup you know
for us you know but i feel like you know
our goals have not changed since
day one you know not to win the super
bowl and to do that
we got to put together another good ball
game against a very worthy opponent
who uh who wants it just as bad as we do
so it's going to be a good challenge
and uh so you know all what happened you
know before doesn't really matter you
know if we if
we don't go out there and handle
business this week so you know for us i
feel like uh you know we fly we're
playing good ball right now
and we're we're definitely in a you know
in a position
to go out there and have a chance uh you
know to to host that lombardi trophy but
before we
do that yeah but before we move to the
buffalo game coleas
um there were two things you just said
there i i wanna i wanna just linger on
for a little bit here is that lamar
coming back
and what that meant you know he said to
michael irvin for for game day morning
this past week that he he he was when he
was
recovering from covet 19 and missing the
game and missing the guys that he he
he really recharged in a way and you
went through it too
i i'm wondering uh you know when you
were going through all that
uh yourself too uh if there was some
sort of recharging renewal or just
uh it was just a dreadful awful
experience that that you're glad to be
done with
but is there anything again of lamar
coming back to you coming back from all
that
that you want to just put out there for
for me i
it just it's fascinating to hear that
the biggest thing from a collective
standpoint
i think the game being taken away from
us for a period of time
you know kind of you know uh it shows
you like you know like how much you left
the game
and like you know not you know i mean
injuries happen and i missed a
bunch of ball games from you know cath
injury as well uh but just it reassures
how much you love the game and uh you
know you kind of realize like man
you know my my team needs me you know
and from talking with them more about it
you know i mean that that was kind of
you know when you when you have to miss
the game
you know uh i mean that's not that's not
fun you know and
seeing the team struggle without you and
don't lose you know makes it even worse
and so just kind of it puts things in
perspective that you know
first of all i need to enjoy this
because it can be taken away from any
moment
and second of all you know i'm gonna
prepare to do my very best
because my team needs me you know and
just being accountable for
one another and then the second thing
you said was when lamar coming back you
said lamar came back from an iv
uh calais um
[Laughter]
is that what he was coming back from
class
i i i get people uh they were they
weren't just buying to me so
the man thought he was coming back from
an iv if he comes back for him i wasn't
there i don't know what happened in the
locker room but my man said he came up
with my iv so that was it
and that's it that's that's uh we'll
we'll just leave it at that right that's
my story
and i'll stick you through it
calais campbell here on the rich eisen
show um hey look
you you mentioned about what this game
means to you and what it means
uh this week and and you know obviously
this is a big matchup and you've got
your hands full with
josh allen and i would ask you normally
a question like that but i'm just going
to go in a different direction for my
last question for you
you're the reigning walter payton man of
the year calais what does it mean to
have that patch on your jersey as you go
about your business
for this team and for this week yeah
it's huge i know i represent
uh uh uh you know just i mean that that
patch represents
you know and uh just an incredible
uh just prestigious uh you know
uh standard of the game you know when
you wear that patch there's a standard
of excellence on and off the field and
just uh from being a teammate
uh to being a leader and and being a
person in the community
uh that you know goes above and beyond
football
and so for me you know i think the
biggest thing is just
uh you know uh living up to that
standard you know i mean this motivation
for me
to to a daily reminder that there's a
standard of excellence
that uh that i want to be accustomed to
and want to
want to make a daily habit and so uh you
know i mean it's both
you know being a great teammate and
being accountable
and living up to it on the field but
also you know never forgetting
about you know uh just the the power
that god bless us with off the field
as athletes and making sure that um you
know i'm keeping
everything in perspective because
football is a beautiful game but it is
a children's game and it's a game that
you know it's a it's a job
and i love you with all my heart uh but
the resources
and uh and the influence it gives us
to be able to go out there and make a
difference in the world is so powerful
and i never want to take that for
granted yeah i mean other players have
c's on their
on their jerseys a lot do but not many
have that patch class
it really is awesome to see and uh
you're you're one of the best
good luck against josh allen you know
you have your hands full right
with that guy yes sir it's gonna be a
great challenge i appreciate you though
you bet you take care of calais thanks
for the call
thank you dude right back at you that's
calais campbell hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here